I'm in the military I was in the
military I'm in the military I was in
the military I was in the military I was
in the military I was in the
military I'm Trevor I'm a marine
Corvette and got out as a lance
corporal uh I'm Dane I'm 26 and I got
out as a hm3 I was in the Navy for 7
years I was just looking at people's
position of attention their at 45° angle
and everything I'm Evette you do not
need to know how old I am but I did 8
years in the
Army my name's Elliot and I served in
the US Marine
Corps my name is Max and I'm an army vet
Max really stuck out he was kind of
dragging his feet and everything a lot
of military guys like don't drag their
feet when they
walk I'm Brandon active duty United
States space
force oh
sick
I'm Susie I'm in the Army Reserves and
I'm a
sergeant space space I've never even
heard of that brand new were you in the
Air Force and then they were like space
force so I was in training I was doing
Roc to be in the Air Force and then uh
2019 is when they created the space
force yeah you're in the space force
like like what so I already saw that it
was going to bring attention to me being
in the space force we don't know about
it so he's probably using that as his
cover so he can make up whatever story
that he wants are you stationed here or
were you stationed Los Angeles for SCE
base yeah but we have a base in Colorado
too okay yeah you guys are unicorns like
you're literally the only one I've ever
no offense to anyone in the space force
but no one knows anything about them but
like your dog tags outside of your shirt
not bothering you like that bothers me
first person I was suspicious of was
Trevor I never like wear these things
they just like wanted me to kind of wear
something marish for the video so oh
gosh all right people who were in the
military you never wear a dog tag that's
like cringy cuz you wear dog tags and
like boot camp who goes to the
VA I haven't yet I've gotten my QTC done
and like done my appointments but I'm
still waiting on the rating okay which
VA what facility do you go to what
facility Lind okay all right no I don't
you don't okay oh I do okay Long Beach
okay why don't you go right are you
still in no I'm a veteran where you go
to boot camp for leonardwood Missouri or
you station oh Cam in Japan that was my
first and only duty station when is that
in Japan it's like an hour away from
Tokyo it's near AI base which is a navy
base like an Air Force Base and then cam
Zama is like right next to it and what
was your MOS MOS is 60 a preventative
medicine
specialist every time I wear them like I
am always wanting to just tuck them
because they're not like supposed to be
worn
[Music]
out when he stepped up and introduced
himself he just said Army veteran he
didn't say anything about like his rank
or anything like that didn't know a damn
thing about the Department of Veterans
Affairs I have never met anybody from
the space
force Dam sorry bro yeah all good good I
believe I can't believe I just got moted
out honestly like just because like I
didn't get VA that's the only reason why
they kind of kicked me out which is kind
of like I wouldn't say dumb but like it
kind of sucks you're on space force like
now you're current now but you have a
beard like what is that all about no sh
Shing profile yeah no shape yeah
I'm still active duty so I this shaving
profile though 8536 2903 I know what the
rag is I'm I'm tell got the
man my commands been on me about that
you got a beard in all of my years I
wasn't able to get a shaving profile
like I don't know this beard is the
evidence that space force isn't a thing
so I kind of wanted him to talk more
about it wait you're an officer Los yeah
Los Angeles B what's your rank uh first
lieutenant yeah you're a sergeant yes
when did you get promoted the sergeant I
got promoted back in November of last
year you look really young to be a
sergeant I'm 25 wow I was like when he
asked me you know like how old am I like
cuz I look young that's when I was like
oh I need to start answering questions
and stuff you're National Guard of
reserves of reserves what do you do in
the reserves so I'm an 88 November I'm a
transportation management coordinator so
basically um my unit we're a small
Detachment and so what we do is we go
out to like the sea ports and basically
like there's vessels with military
equipment we basically like offload them
or upload them and then kind of like
send them where they need to be for uh
the Marines what unit were you guys in
35 and weapons and field training
Battalion Edson range yeah what company
were you with HZ with 24 and then Bravo
with5 okay I um yeah I knew some guys in
Joker 24 but okay yeah Joker yeah I see
what's
this
going I don't know nothing about no
Marines I don't know if you guys are
tracking quiet there's the
Marine you're super quiet right to have
the big marine guy with the shirt and
everything so I was like it would be too
obvious where did you serve I was in
first fast first and then I went to 9 I
was Yankee white and then I was an 0311
with5 with5 mhm what what company Bravo
and then H&S I went to rat in 05 oh yeah
same unit yeah the only other person
that stood out to me was DNE he said he
was in the Navy but I noticed that the
logo on his shirt was actually a Marine
Corps unit what's the mission of the
Marine Corps Rifle Squad to close with
the Enemy close with and destroy the
enemy locate close with and destroy the
Enemy by fire maneuver repel enemy
assault by fire and close combat yep I
didn't
remember for sure I had that hazed into
me by my seniors so you know I've
learned it pretty quick and when did you
ETS 2007
yeah it's ET yeah ETA but e Army it's
ETS oh is different different for every
Branch yeah oh really
ETS for the Army ETS for the Army term
of service a vet was kind of next in
line to be voted off maybe it was just
cuz it had been a while and she had
forgotten like some little aspects of
the military um so why' you guys join
College I wasn't really that passionate
about many career fields or anything
like that but one thing that I did find
passion in was camaraderie and a bunch
of people unifying together towards one
goal I joined because do you remember
that Marine Corps commercial with the
guy on the on the bridge slaying the
dragon that's made out of fire from like
back in the '90s
for that that Dr I don't remember this
it sounds like a good commercial though
the Marine Corp has the best propaganda
out of every Branch I walked through
Rec's office and I was like oh
man wow two things like I joined the
reserves first right so I was a
reservist yeah so I got into um I
reclassified and did um Intel uh so I
joined in 2016 I think it was a
combination of like patriotism and just
also the benefits were very attractive
to me like you know a route to pay for
school I come from a military family uh
my sister was in the Air Force but yeah
that was kind of my reasoning if I went
to college right after high school I
would have just like been a dumbass and
dropped out within a semester might as
well be a badass become a Marine
infantry man and you know that's kind of
what I did I joined um in 2017 and I did
a semester of college and then like this
recruiter like came up to me and was
like Hey like do you want to join the
Army like I feel like you would be a
good fit maybe she's been lying this
whole time he didn't tell you about
basic training oh yeah he told me about
okay yeah
yeah no yeah I went to basic training
and AIT and then like came back and then
I was like okay cool I could like go to
[Music]
college do you think you know who the
mole
is make sure that you like and subscribe
so that you can see
more it's got to be the beard uh I get
that he has a No Shave chip but still
out of everyone like that just kind of
makes me uh
suspicious so EV was in a little
suspicious of me so I was thinking maybe
if I vote her out then I could clear the
air for me
space force sorry bro space force isn't
real you going to regret that I feel
disrespected and it was pretty much a
bunch of Marines so they had their
little p out and that's cool and all but
you got to put respect on the space
force because without us good luck if
everyone feels confident that you
already caught them all you can end the
game now but if the majority has doubt
the game will continue so please raise
your hand if you want to continue the
game confident group all right look at
that if the lights turn green you voted
the mole out and you win if the lights
turn red you didn't vote the mole out
and you lose if we didn't we be pissed
ready
three
two yeah
1 2
[Music]
3 I knew I
knew I'm a military dependent my dad
served 20 years um in the US Navy he
retired in 2008 um I was born and raised
all on Military basis whether that's
from like Hawaii California Japan just
back and forth military bases camama is
a real base in Japan I'm independent all
my homies are in the Army all my homies
are
all the branches there isn't one type of
person who goes into the Marine Corps
the Army if you are a veteran if you're
about to get out or if you plan on
getting out my recommendation is just to
nurture those parts of you that are not
in the military I think that everybody
in the audience should do a little more
research on the space force acknowledge
and respect that we are an actual branch
and then without us there's a lot of
your day-to-day life that you can go
without and put respect does it take to
open the box you know
what
yes if you want to join the Marine Court
talk to Sergeant Evan Rodriguez Palm
Desert this is the bonus that I never
got for my
Enlistment